hello everybody hope that you're good
the last video aged pretty well I mean
everything we said is pretty much
happening right now so I'm very happy
that that's the case feeling blessed and
also want to say thank you to all of you
for your support I'm receiving a lot of
messages these days saying that well
thanks to the information that I
provided it help you to be prepared for
this case for this wi F idea that it
happened and it helped you to first save
money and second to get advantage of
this move so I'm very feeling very
honored I'm very humbled that that's the
case um yeah just wanted to say thank
you for all those messages now in this
video of course we're want to talk about
this long week we're want to analyze uh
what has happened and what it's
potentially going to happen in the
future uh but the whole video is not
going to be about the week like the last
one we're also going to talk about some
structure that I'm seeing right here
we're also going to go to the Bitcoin
dominance for a while
Solana Sol Solana is moving very nicely
and it's one of those coins that right
now along with Bitcoin I'm I'm charting
the best I'm fully positioned into
Solana at the moment both in a sport and
in Futures so yeah I have a few things
to say about that but anyway let's let's
get started so the first thing is this
long week all right long weeks are
imbalances in the chart that tend to get
filled they also represent open interest
gaps because with these sharp moves
there are many orders that haven't been
triggered and this Market is quite
efficient right so at the end of the day
well the exchanges and what the market
maker wants to make is money and that
money gets earned by fees and the way
that they get those fees is by uh
Traders engaging and into the chart and
opening trades closing closing trades
and for that they need to fill sometimes
those open interest gaps on this long
week
which in my opinion is pretty much the
same and that's the way I put put it
together okay that's to me the
theoretical part of the week FL strategy
but anyway we talk more about that in
the in the course that should be by the
way ready by next month the start of the
year we haven't had it for five five
months or more but I'll be happy to
reopen in some slots again because I see
so many people interested so uh yeah
might be might be time to open those
slots again but in in that case then
based on my observation the 50% level of
the week it's a very interesting Zone
where we often see reactions okay so
that's why I always Mark the 50% level
because I go level by level so it's
possible to expect a a bounce off from
that level now if that level doesn't
hold then yes you can go back to the
100% of the week but um here in terms of
trading um it's quite simple okay and
you can open a limit order of the 50% of
the week see if there is a reaction now
if there is a reaction like what
happened here then you could see price
going back here that's fine but what you
don't want to see is consolidation here
okay if you saw some consolidation here
at the 50% level that usually signals
that price is going to go down to the
100% of the week so the only way to
trade this is manually okay any Trader
that he was trading that we F strategy
with a stop loss uh in this zone I'm
sorry that's a bad Trader you don't do
that that's not how you trade the long
week okay the the the way to invalidate
is manually you need to see
consolidation because uh you cannot
trade blindly you need to see what price
action is actually doing what is the
intention and to this kind of traders in
many occasions what they see is price
hitting their stop losses and then
continue going higher all right so yeah
I want to mention that because also you
can take the information because if
price do something like this which I
don't think it will but if he does and
it starts to consolidate here then yes
could that trade off get out price is
going to go to the 100% but that is
likely not going to happen all right now
I'll tell you what I think is the
situation here I think that this week is
done the 50% level go filled therefore
the imbalance to me is completed is done
and based on that now you can start to
look for some structures here so you
want to notice this trend line here that
if we Mark you go that trend line you
had the long week that week has to get
filled it gets filled exactly to the 50%
here you start to see weeks to the
downside but price not pring any lower
which means that there is a reversal
happening this is a deviation you are
back above the trend line and now the
trend line could act as support
to continue going up okay that's what I
think I think that price can continue
going higher um that's how that's the
way I position myself okay so yeah in my
opinion that was a deviation uh a lot of
Traders go liquidity here we also talk
remember guys in the telegram Channel I
think it was or in YouTube I don't
remember we talk about this long week
here in the 4-Hour time frame that week
was already telling you guys don't panic
here don't panic of the 50% okay don't
worry because you have this other long
week here the price needs to go back too
so maybe they s you out a tiny bit but
price eventually needs to go back up get
that week done all right and so far
right now the structure is intact
because that's just a deviation the
structure hasn't changed you are back
above the 4H hour 50
Ma and the the trend is to the upside so
in my opinion the next few weeks few
months for Bitcoin are looking pretty
good because um in my opinion yes this
was a very big imbalance I need to get
filled as soon as possible and as I said
much better if we can fill a week
straight away get done with that long
week there because now price has filled
a week that's a deviation the trend line
is perfect can continue going up in
price but if we didn't feel this long
week then okay price could go go high
and then it would need to have a sharp
drop back to this level back to the week
and maybe that would break the bullish
structure so as I said with long weeks
the sooner they get filled the better
because you can forget about them price
do need to go back down now okay price
can continue going up in my opinion so
um that's all I have to think for
Bitcoin and now if you didn't take any
entry in um Trend environment I would
recommend making use of the 50 EMA so
depends now if you are a scaler a day
trader a swing Trader then you're going
to choose your time frame but pay
attention to the 50 EMA okay and that's
where you can take some good entries in
Bitcoin and in altcoins now if you go to
the Bitcoin dominance which I think is
the most interesting chart at the moment
H without any doubt even more
interesting than Bitcoin is is giving us
a lot of information and we can trade
based on this Bo very quick analysis
here okay um I like to do it in every
video so you guys understand the
context the big Arrow the this
projection that's high time frame this
is small one is low time frame from the
last video I posted on Saturday today is
Wednesday okay
so pretty much I'll go very quickly you
had a range here for two years you see
very sad
reactions and pullbacks from the
resistance you can see there it takes
two candles however here you have
consolidation in resistance there is
something that changing the behavior is
different that already tells you that
price is potentially going to break up
we call that in a video price breaks up
pulls back to the top of the range we
call that to continuation as we said
towards 60% to fill up all these
inefficent is here these liquidity pools
those long candles all right and
eventually we said 61 to 55% that's your
level but not only that price should
deviate above it to confirm that there
is going to be a downtrend and if you go
into the 4our time frame you can see
that very clear deviates above it and
drops so now what we have here is a high
time frame downtrend at the moment if we
go into the daily time frame I don't
think that this is a corrective move I
think well corrective move in a uptrend
I don't think that's the case I think
it's going down eventually towards 52%
that's our first Target and on Saturday
video we were talking about this
Behavior here which it was long weeks at
the lows but price is not progressing
any further it's not breaking lower why
well because the market maker is making
sure the price is holding here before
reversing okay that's what happens in
every single chart that's uh part of my
trading system now what you see there
was a push up towards this box that we
marked also you have that the daily 50ma
resistance is acting a resistance going
to the four time frame you can see here
better so
far that box there it's a very strong
resistance okay so what are we going to
see are we going to see the Bitcoin
dominance going lower down
retrace down okay that's what I think it
is now time is only going to prove me
right or wrong about this sometimes I'm
right sometimes I'm wrong so let's see
what happens but in my opinion the
Bitcoin dominance should continue going
down all right um that's what I think
simply because I don't see any other
reason let's go back to the weekly time
frame I don't see any other reason why
it should continue going higher we've
already filled all these imbalances we
deviated at that level why should it
continue higher I don't find any reason
at the moment okay so yes to me Let It
Go lower 52% if 52% breaks from here
then perhaps we go again to the range
highs now I don't know if we want to
fall back into the range okay to the
range lows that would be a very epic all
season I don't think if we go that low
or not at the moment uh difficult to
tell but so far I'm waiting on Al coins
all this time since here okay because
it's in a downtrend very clearly to me
so that's a bit
dominance now if you go to the total
three this is basically the the chart
the marks the altcoin market and stable
coins so here we was saying that the
Bitcoin dominance was going to pull back
to the
upsite okay while Bitcoin was going to
go down to fill the 50% of the week then
Al coins based on this they were going
to drop lower between a 10 and a 20% now
if we Mark here what happened this week
you're going to notice that that is
exactly 17 or 18% okay this includes
stable coins so yeah it was more like 20
25% in several altcoins but pretty much
um that was on point which it was a very
uh I was even shocked that I was right
about that because a few things have to
happen in order for this to to play out
and yes the Bitcoin dominance went up
Bitcoin went down altcoins gave us that
very sharp pullback to the downside
where we could add into our current spot
backs or long
positions uh in the case of ethereum at
resistance I do think that eventually
will break above here above this level
you only need some consolidation above
this all right and then go up same as
with the Bitcoin dominance so far at
this level we are seeing very sharp
retraces however if we start to see a
bit of consolidation here either below
or above I don't care that's change of
behavior change of environment if we see
that price is potentially signaling a
breakout to 5,500 is right so that's
what I think for ethereum any VP is for
buying
next Solana let's go into the daily time
frame we've been talking about this idea
since we were around 230 240 we were
talking that a pullback was potentially
going to happen in Solana below the
previous high as a
deviation that's what we marked and
that's what happened while the daily 50a
was going to be holding price in order
to continue the trend
uh all right so we could continue going
higher so far that's what happened you
can see here if we zoom in deviation
below the white line that's the previous
High daily 50 ma holding price should
continue going higher going to the 4H
hour time frame
guys look at that also in the telegram
Channel we talked yesterday there is a
very long week that long week is going
to get retrace that's your second entry
because I know that many of you uh were
not checking the charts at the time that
this happened this long week and then
you probably thought oh damn I missed
this opportunity what can I do and I
answered to some guys in the in Telegram
in the telegram group chat and I was
saying I think that it's very likely
that we go back to the to that week so
uh you haven't missed anything you can
still get in um that's what happened at
the same time as we were holding above
the daily 50 Ma and now we're finding
resistance at the 4H hour 50 ma now if
if you are thinking about entering
again um I'll tell you what my plan is
uh I enter both in a spot and Futures
around 210
209 okay um in a spot I'm holding until
we make a new a new at the highest
around 300 that's probably what I start
to to sell and that's in the spot and in
Futures my plan is I think that price is
likely going want to go to this level
however we're a resistance so feel free
to sell some of your positions I think I
might do that now I might sell maybe 20
25% of my current long position from the
lows and my idea is um to pretty much
close most of my position here around
240 you can see that that area could be
quite a strong resistance you can see
that there however what I'm expecting is
price to go back to go to the level
retrace back into the 4H hour 50 and
that's what I can take another entry
okay because that is telling me okay
that could be a new um higher low
because if you notice here you have
lower low lower low lower low now what
you need here is well perhaps we don't
make a higher high here but we can make
a higher low okay and that could signal
that price is likely going to go higher
so that's what I'm thinking for son at
the moment it's looking really good both
in spot and in future so I'm very happy
trading this now if we go into other
altcoins for example Tia you can see
also this structure we're talking about
potential deviation below the range
highs we've got it it went even lower
daily 50ma is holding very well
potentially we are getting back above
the range size if that is the case that
is telling me that that was a ShakeOut
deviation price should go to $12 okay
which is this peot point here and
look this is pretty much what is
happened okay sometimes here you get
first this shake out okay that deviation
there as you can see here but then price
is eventually going to go towards that
take profits there all right so I think
that's where we are and like this you
can see other Al coins Manta another one
that I've got in look at this is the
same exact chart same structure guys
same structure you have a range here you
have a peot level another P level I I
open here two entries the first one was
that dotted line that pivot and the
other one was at the Range High average
entries in the lower part of the middle
lower middle part here so pretty much at
the daily 50ma support so as long as I
don't lose the daily 50ma I'm not close
in my position manually that's my
validation but in my opinion something
like this should happen look at that
people level the same as Tia is 12 here
for man is
1.83 all right that's my take profits in
a spot all right so that's the way that
I'm trading this current environment
anyway guys that's pretty much
everything that I wanted to say thank
you very much for watching and I'll see
you soon